that actually stemmed from our
conversation about whether AI is going
to kill all of us and you we've
discussed this kind of
spreading of intelligence through really
all space that in practice it just seems
that things get more complicated things
are more complicated than the story of
well if you build the thing that's plus
one intelligence that thing will be able
to build the thing that's plus two
intelligence and plus three intelligence
and that will be exponential it'll
become uh more intelligent exponentially
faster and so on until it completely
destroys everything
um but you know that intuition might
still not be so simple but I might still
care carry validity and there's two
interesting trajectories here one a
super intelligence system remains in
rule
proximity to humans to where we're like
holy crap this thing is really
intelligent uh let's select the present
and then there could be perhaps more
terrifying intelligence that starts
moving away they might be around us now
they're moving far away in really of
space but they're still sharing physical
Resources with us yes yes so they can
rob us of those physical resources and
Destroy Humans just kind of casually
yeah just just uh like nature code like
nature could but it seems like there's
something unique about AI systems where
um
there is a this kind of exponential
growth like the way well sorry Nature
has so many things in it one of the
things that nature has which is very
interesting are viruses for example
there is systems within nature that have
this kind of exponential effect
and that terrifies us humans because it
can you know there's only eight billion
of us and you can just kind of it's not
that hard to just kind of whack them all
real quick so uh I mean is that
something you think about that yeah I
vote about that yes the threat of it I
mean are you as concerned about it as uh
somebody like Elias yokowski for example
just big big painful negative effects of
AI on society
you know no but perhaps that's because
I'm intrinsically an optimist
um I mean I think that there are things
I think the thing that one you know one
sees is there's going to be this one
thing and it's going to just zap
everything somehow you know I maybe I
have faith in computational
irreducibility so to speak that there's
always unintended little Corners that
you know it's just like somebody says
I'm going to oh I don't know somebody
has some some bio weapon and they say
we're going to release this and it's
going to do all this harm but then it
turns out it's more complicated than
that because you know the kind of some
humans are different and you know the
exact way it works is a little different
than you expect it's something where
sort of the the the great big you you
know you smash the thing with something
you know you the asteroid collides with
the Earth yeah and it kind of you know
and yes you know the Earth is cold for
two years or something and you know then
lots of things die but not everything
dies and it's you know there's there's
usually I mean I I kind of this is in a
sense the sort of story of computational
irreducibility there are always
unexpected Corners there always
unexpected consequences and I don't
think that they're kind of whack it over
the head with something and then it's
all gone is you know that can obviously
happen the Earth can be swallowed up in
a black hole or something and then it's
kind of presumably presumably all over
um the uh but but you know I think this
question of of what you know what what
do I think the realistic paths are I
think that there will be sort of an
increasing I mean the the people have to
get used to phenomena like computational
irreducibility there's an idea that we
built the machines so we can understand
what they do and we're we're going to be
able to control what happens well that's
not really right now the question is is
the result of that lack of control going
to be that the machine's kind of
conspire and sort of wipe us out maybe
just because I'm an optimist I don't
tend to think that that's you know
that's in the cards I think that the you
know as a realistic thing I suspect you
know what will sort of emerge maybe is
kind of an ecosystem of the AIS just as
you know again I I don't really know I
mean this is something that's it's hard
to it's hard to be clear about what will
happen
um I mean I think that the you know
there are there are a lot of sort of
details of you know what could we do
what systems in the world could we
connect and AI to you know I have to say
I was just a couple of days ago I was
working on this uh chat gbt plug-in kit
that we have for open language okay
where you can you know you can create a
plugin and it runs with language code
um and it can run more from language
code back on your own computer yeah and
I was thinking well I can just make it
you know I can tell chat gbt create a
piece of code and then just run it on my
computer and I'm like you know that that
sort of personalizes for me the what
could what could possibly go wrong so to
speak was that exciting or scary that
possibility
it was a little bit scary actually
because it's kind of like like I realize
I'm I'm delegating to the AI just write
a piece of code you know you're in
charge write a piece of code run it on
my computer
and pretty soon all my files exactly
let's take a uh that's like Russian
Roulette but like much more complicated
yeah yes yes right that's a good
drinking game I don't know so well uh
right I mean
it's an interesting question then if you
do that right what is the sandboxing
that you should have and that's sort of
a that's a a version of of that question
for the world that is as soon as you put
the AIS in charge of things you know how
much how many constraints should there
be on these systems before you put the
AIS in charge of all the weapons and all
these you know all these different kinds
of systems well here's the fun part
about sandboxes is uh the AI knows about
them it has the tools to uh crack them
look the fundamental problem of computer
security is computational irreducibility
yes because the fact is any sandbox is
never any you know it's never going to
be a perfect sandbox if you want the
system to be able to do interesting
things I mean this this is the a problem
that's happened the generic problem of
computer security that as soon as you
have your you know firewall that is
sophisticated enough to be a universal
computer that means it can do anything
and so long as if you find a way to poke
it so that you actually get it to do
that Universal computation thing that's
the way you kind of crawl around and get
her to do the thing that it wasn't
intended to do and that's sort of a
another version of computational
irreducibility is you can you know you
can kind of you get it to do the thing
you didn't expect it to do so to speak
there's so many interesting
possibilities here that manifest
themselves from the compute
computationally reducibility here
it's just so many things could happen
because in digital space things move so
quickly you can have a chat bot you can
have a piece of code that
you could basically have chat GPT
generated viruses accidentally or on
purpose and they the digital viruses yes
and uh they could be brain viruses too
do they they convince kind of like uh
phishing emails yes they can convince
you of stuff yes and no doubt you can
you know in a sense we've had the loop
of the machine learning Loop of making
things that convince people of things
yeah it's surely going to get easier to
do yeah and you know then what does that
look like well it's again you know we
humans are you know we're this is a new
environment for us and admittedly it's
an environment which a little bit
scarily is is changing much more rapidly
but then I mean you know people worry
about you know climate change is going
to happen over hundreds of years and you
know the environment is changing but the
environment for you know in the the kind
of digital environment might change in
in six months